Fred's uh first Dream your first dream
was to be music you had no idea that you
would end up in comedy acting television
improv whatever you're doing you was
music was your it was music although in
the back of my mind I I really loved
SNL so I think somewhere in there there
was like a mix of the two why'd you
leave SNL yeah I did 11 years 11 Seasons
right and it's one of those things where
I remember Amy polar describing it as
like you just can feel it you're like I
think I've said what I wanted to say and
Bill ha was leaving Jason sedus Seth I
think soon after so it was sort of like
our group was starting to kind of move
on in a way is that a hard thing because
I would think like that's a dream to be
on SNL and I as one you you just talked
about remember we were walking around
and I told you in the studio right and
then I I'm this is my 14th season on AG
I can't
imagine leaving you know what I mean
it's I want to be I want to be uh fired
or uh let go I don't want to be but I'm
just saying I can't I don't disagree
with you I I I can't leave parties
that's why I don't go to parties it's a
really it's a It's
Complicated um and the one good thing is
you don't really ever leave I go back
every every season and I'll do a little
something I'm still friends with cast
members and with Lauren so in a way you
kind of stay but the way that that show
works is it needs to have like new cast
members it needs to kind of keep I get
it but you were a cast member who wasn't
being asked to leave you you're going on
your own fruition which that is a crazy
move CRA I agree it's a crazy move but
it felt right I was doing this other
show Portlandia can I ask a serious
question yeah I I feel like I'm
derailing the podcast a little bit with
a serious question but do you you say
you go back to SNL from time to time and
you never actually leave you don't go
there and miss it and want to go back
ever it's like the equivalent of missing
um like in a like college or something
mhm where you loved it and it was really
fun and then you I don't want to go back
and and do the actual grind of writing
every week and trying to come up with a
new character that's a great analogy
that was a great analogy who's your
least favorite person that came on SNS
in this room
[Music]
um it's it was all great honestly no
you're lying fact that you had honestly
there had to be an that you had
to run in with or they had to run in
with that was really hard you know we've
all read about the Steven seagals and
but I wasn't there no I know you weren't
there so what what I'm saying is there
had to be those kind of moments every
week you have a new guest host my
experience was everyone
was very kind very funny really nice
everyone yeah everyone absolutely
everyone was funny kind and nice all
great you're a liar no I'm telling you
no you're a liar maybe positive he's
just a very positive person did you ever
have a fight with a fellow oh he's
laughing again why does he laugh just
like this me laugh I'm sorry that's not
a laugh you're you're a liar um he's
very he's a very nice person didn't
break you into laugh
after not everyone was funny but
sometimes funny is overrated anyway
really yeah I sometimes like if someone
was like uh an athlete or a politician
sometimes it was just better because it
was just weirder and I love that it
served the sketch
[Music]
better